foreign
[Music]
ER 22 here
you may know that Joe Biden was recently
seen with a blood-filled left eye during
the climate town hall to ignore me this
is just more proof that this actual
[ __ ] baby boomer is too old to
support a closed circulatory system
while this is true the more important
truth you'll hear is that
is it this answers
The Reptilian question
this artist on pole pointed out the
similarities between Joe Biden and a
horned lizard with this disgusting
ability to squirt blood from its eye
Uncle Joe must have felt threatened by
so many questions and just couldn't
suppress his Natural Instincts
I shouldn't even have to mention the
other obvious similarity of that old
creepy Joe shares with a horny lizard
thanks for watching if you want to
support me you can pledge to my GoFundMe
and help my command center move to a
better space to make videos apparently I
can only work on videos at night when my
mom's asleep until next time listen blow
her out
listening
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
you
really did help me out with that honey
I'm glad that local that local South
America he was very passionate about it
you got to try this honey like a Jewish
guy with the doctors like you've never
seen honey
[Laughter]
raw from a local Farm he's like that's
crap what do you know from honey you
best if you don't know honey
this you think your honey's clear this
honey is so clear
it's like the Jewish Donald Trump in
terms of he's the honey Jackie Mason
you know it's raw honey so you from the
Orange Bowl I found a Honey's like like
wine I guess people you know what
comment below if you're a honey
connoisseur depends on what flowers they
I don't know that's the whole thing yeah
someone was doing a honey tasting
somewhere you do that no I don't know it
was a bear yes you see him ping
uh I also love that if you go into the
woods today you're in for a big surprise
oh no you mean you'd be surprised that
there are bears in the woods or trees I
mean I guess I'd be surprised of a
picnic yes I mean like that's pretty
organized I assumed it was allegorical
that by picnic they mean that they were
they were tearing people apart oh yeah
yeah that's what I would expect if I go
into the woods I saw Grizzly Man so we
had a lot to talk about today the
Nordstrom pipeline right what's happened
there there are a lot of conspiracies
going around
I would I will I don't know I don't know
exactly what happened nobody really
knows but we have a scorecard for the
United States could they be involved
Russia Ukraine and who is most likely so
there'll be discussion about that today
we'll also be discussing that Velma from
Scooby-Doo is now a lesbian interesting
yeah uh yeah so she's I think this is
all one big glorified advertisement for
Orvis
and then uh
Elon Musk now he's going to be buying
Twitter that just went through that is
official so my question to you is do you
think that uh you think he'll reinstate
Donald Trump's Twitter account
also I was banned from Tick Tock which
is fun finally yep so we'll be doing
that and a whole lot more to Gerald how
are you I'm doing well how are you man I
just had a popcorn kernel come loose in
my mouth when were you eating popcorn
last night
that could have been three weeks ago
you know when they turn off like they
get in your gums like those things hurt
yeah man sure you keep they said your
hands you're right keep talking no no no
yeah
someone help me put the put the camera
on him tool man
it just can't it just came loose it was
in the back of my gum I couldn't get rid
of it it just came on so I was saying
all right okay fastest man in his feet
quickest way in the west he also you
know him you love him Dave Landau how
are you Ahoy good yourself Colonel lists
no kernels in you no no kernels I try to
avoid the popcorn unless I'm at the big
picture shows is that because of the
kernels it's because of the kernels it
really it just gets stuck I've been
doing that all day I can't stop doing it
I'll get one in my gum and then the gum
grows over it yes it feels like it not
really it does it feels like it yes
really I gotta get out tweezers old
thing it's yeah it is a thing and by the
way speaking of thing I'll be in
Oklahoma City this weekend uh Saturday
October 8th there's a sixth show we
added an 8 45 show so you can go to
livecredible.com tour like I said the
people who run these clubs are good
people and they won't be bullied let me
tell you how great that club is uh owner
that texted me yesterday to include how
much I like it too
[Laughter]
likes it all right I love it I love his
clubs yes he's like you could throw in
on that I'm like you're a bastard
s uh first really quickly there was a
group of women on a podcast here that's
been making the rounds uh and I guess
the host I'm not familiar with it but
the host kind of you know called on the
task and they didn't know what to do
with it they're proclaiming what a
wonderful thing it is uh for women in
their 20s to not be in relationships and
they use these broad terms like explore
themselves anyway just see how this goes
down yeah like when I take someone
seriously when clearly yeah not taking
me seriously at all especially because
we're all like in our early 20s like
this is the time to like explore and
find yourself too when you say explore
and find yourself does that mean just
like get run through by a bunch of dudes
I'm just translating
the correct answer is yes that's what
they meant
for girls yes here's the thing you're
like we're in our 20s yeah you know you
know World War II was won by women in
their 20s like that was a big part of
you know the war effort like back in the
day women in their 20s were working they
had children they had established
families they had a home I know that you
say that's the deck is decked against
you so you can't you you can't do it
it's completely untrue you don't have to
in your 20s have a bunch of meaningless
relationships in one night stands if you
want to fine just don't espouse it to
other girls although that's the norm
they play baseball with Rosie O'Donnell
yep
they did that too yes until their window
closes that's the problem there's no
ovulating
it no
pain that long oh no
women look here's and and we'll get to
Megan Kelly in a second now she's taking
Flack because what she said about the
Kardashians same kind it's this vanity
look
it is true it is there is a double
standard just to be clear there is a
double it's not that we're setting it
biology is setting the standard men
don't have that kind of a window man can
have kids well into their gosh Abraham I
mean you go like it probably into your
90s I don't know but I'm sure it can be
done I mean you need assistance but uh
you do have a certain winner if you're
saying oh I'm gonna waste my 20s and
women often get into their 30s and they
go oh they end up settling say I'm not
going to settle for anything less than
perfect when you're in your 20s and then
you end up settling for a trash bag in
your 30s because now you're up against
the clock and I'm not saying just to be
clear people use this term [ __ ] shaming
all the time no look that's not I'm not
[ __ ] shaming anybody okay that being
said
look can we all acknowledge that not
most women are [ __ ] okay let's be
clear about not not probably not even a
plurality okay
but some are
yeah
and it's a bad idea are we not allowed
to say that some are at this point I
don't know if you're just going on your
and you're going into it with the
mindset of I am going to sleep around I
this because it's my 20s
some women are and we'd like to thank
your dad
[Laughter]
the one that didn't go to jail right and
the guy who kissed you at the PTA I mean
what
what are serious about you don't don't
settle for
that obviously aren't taking you
seriously by the way if you want to be
taken seriously be somebody that can be
taken seriously as well you didn't quite
young I get it it's this Baseline it's
this Baseline of wow we're in our 20s
this is what we do something happens you
know I was in college so I you know was
getting ripped all the time look I I
drink I'm not someone who I don't drink
a lot I have no problem with people who
drink I have no problem with people who
uh do these things responsibly but to
say well the Baseline is if you're in
college it's four four years of
glorified alcoholism it doesn't have to
be that way right and this is
perpetuated by of course the
entertainment industry saying this is
what women should do in your 20s this is
what this is what you should do in
college no no no you can make good
decisions at any point in your life and
they're so dumbfounded like is that what
no that's not what we mean well what do
you mean I mean you know have a bunch of
relationships and sleep with a lot of
guys okay here's the issue and I will
say it is a double standard when people
say why am I a [ __ ] if I do this and men
aren't okay
that is true here's why you're the
GateKeeper
you can women should say no and men
should of course respect no to be clear
but your set point women you control
access to sex right because your natural
set point is no I don't know prove your
worth a man's natural set point is
please so you are the rate limiting
factor take advantage of it we've tried
to empower women by stripping them of
something with which they're powerful
the ability to to pick a Suitor you've
given it away yeah you have uh you have
value yes you know you have inherent
value yeah that you can use like if I
ever hit rock bottom I just can't go out
and sell myself no you can't no no it's
just gonna be the other men yes exactly
conjugal visits
and that being said Dave just so you
know you know how big of a heart this
guy has he does the conjugal visits just
to put a smile on their face I do it is
I do and they agree near to ear yeah
Dave Dave goes down to these hurricane
stricken areas and he's like guys I'm
open season I know it's a tough time yes
my mouth it's his version of USA it's
just it's just FEMA and him and titty
tests I please them with the tornado yes
that's what they call it huh it's an F5
yes that's more like an F1 so this dies
do we have it Megan Kelly Megan Kelly is
catching Flack right now and I for
wherever you line up if you agree with
Megan Kelly or not it's like a penis I'm
sorry oh okay okay there's a rocket
going on I know we're all children guys
oh boy I'm not that does though so Megan
Kelly is catching Flack for what she
said people are mislabeling this just
saying she just called the Kardashians
that's actually not what she said and I
think she had a pretty good point and I
think that she actually couched it
pretty effectively and I think that a
lot of women would do well too
listen to it and by the way man you
would do well to look for a woman who uh
expresses these kinds of sentiments and
values it's just opinion let's roll
Megan Kelly
um what I object to back on the
Kardashians is the
unrivaled vanity
like the self-promotional out of control
focus on one's self ego clicks likes
they're hugely responsible for that in
our society they didn't do it by
themselves but more than any other
they've had a terrible effect in that
lane and I do blame them I do I asked
them I interviewed them and I said are
you a Force for good or are you a force
for evil and they gave me their answer
but the more I've watched them over the
years the more I think net net it's evil
I don't think this is healthy and that's
what I object to it's like they're
disgusting vanity which is spread like
wildfire in our society the the selfie
culture is abhorrent to me I think
that's what I'm responding to as opposed
to some titillation from a beautiful
woman here and there and she was talking
about how there were some spreads where
there were some new spreads you know in
an appropriate venue how she doesn't
have a problem with that look I agree
with you and people get really they get
really up in arms when you use the term
evil why because that means you're
making a moral judgment yeah we're not
allowed to do that anymore right if you
say well you shouldn't say do that so
that's shaming no I was evil what are
you saying no no look look you serve a
master
we need to acknowledges and people who
are serving ultimately evil can do good
things and people who are trying to do
good can do evil things that is true but
if you are not serving good if you are
not pursuing good ultimately you are at
the very least a valuable tool in the
service of evil and you have to ask
do you think it's a good thing for young
women to say hey I could go to school I
could become a nurse I could go to
school I could become an engineer or I
can have sex with a DJ and sell it for
millions of dollars
it's the vanity it's the self-worship a
lot of people think idolatry is a golden
calf look no people idolize themselves
it's self-worship you've created
yourself as your own Idol doesn't mean
that you can't be beautiful doesn't mean
that you shouldn't understand like we
just said you're worth your value but
that shouldn't be the value that
supersedes everything else in your life
and we really have placed an
unbelievable premium on on vanity and
unfortunately it is it's a path right
now it's the the easiest path to success
for a lot of young women you see it all
the time I mean young women like it
wasn't an option just only fans That's
not healthy I can't believe somebody
insulted a Kardashian
nerve stepped out on a limb but she's
catching Flack for it not because people
hate the Kardashians but they hate the
moral judgment more like how dare you
say look it's her opinion I think I
think she's right yeah yeah I mean I
don't know I don't know is is it really
a chicken or the egg thing though I mean
you have to look at reality television
yeah before them I mean OJ as a result
they were spawned off of that or making
money by whatever you want to call the
influencing whatever it is there's so
much of that in our culture that I
wouldn't just blame them like I wouldn't
be able to call them evil and not just
say it's kind of part of the entire
internet wave that we've created as a
culture but you didn't call them evil
that's like you don't say you're evil
she's saying the culture of it can be
she's saying yes are you a force for
evil in other words people may not
realize that she's not saying you're an
evil person but ultimately it's an evil
force look young women are unhappy and
young men don't want to get married you
can argue till you're blue in the face
so what we're saying is wrong and it's
offensive but it's like that's just a
fact women are less happy than ever
in modern American history and young
fewer men than ever want to get married
and women are you saying all women want
not all women but most women want to get
married and that's becoming uh you're
having Slimmer and Slimmer prospects is
that ultimately are you being a Force
for good really this is an open-ended
conversation I'd love to hear what you
guys have to say about it I think it's
more important than taxes
[Music]
also velma's a lesbian
never could have seen that coming you
talking about that lesbo from Scooby-Doo
I'm talking about the lesbo from Scooby
talking about that ugly broad who has no
prospects I guess switch teams yeah and
I would have gotten away with it too if
not for those scissoring kids
[Music]
so here's Scooby-Doo now uh Velma uh
this is is now I guess officially or
unofficially oh jinkies uh
was it no zoik Screech yeah
I walked in and they were doing it
but if you think it's weird how
Scooby-Doo eats a sandwich you should
see Velma what I found was it a ghost no
[Music]
there we go velma's a lesbian
[Music]
I'm sure that Coco made some brilliant
observations in the encounter we just
had the cute ones right
show them my brilliant observations okay
so look come on here's the macro I don't
care if you want to have a lesbian
character right now there is a pro when
you have when you have people who are
gay or lesbian which is atypical and by
that I mean you know it's always been
about two percent of the population now
it's claimed to be seven when you go
lgbtq AIP and that includes queer and
bisexual uh a very small percentage of
the population so it necessitates a
conversation with kids hold on a second
what is that why is a woman why is a
woman making out with a woman why are
they having a romantic relationship
because it doesn't necessitate a sexual
follow-up question if you just see a man
and a woman because that is the norm
right it does if it's a typical kids ask
question so I don't think it should be
ejected into kids shows the other thing
though is look there are plenty of
lesbian characters and gay characters
that there's not a problem with that
right the BBC has it as low as a
references available at lotto.com 2021
they said 12 percent of all ustv
characters were lgbtq and I've actually
spent numbers as high as 16 let's call
it 12 14 it's still at least more than
double likely triple that of the pot
there are plenty of gay and lesbian
characters they're just not as popular
so if we're going to [ __ ] about
appropriation why do you need to take a
straight character and make her lesbian
just go make your own it's not our fault
people don't want to watch it just
because we don't want to watch a bunch
of cartoon women shop at Bass Pro
foreign
she's ever set by the way which was a
little bit weird that was a little weird
yeah yeah and she's never really worn
anything that's a Fox News camera yeah
it was I want more legs glasses presents
Scooby-Doo
I found the ghost of ales in The Green
Room oh oh boy they're septoplasting me
up everywhere
but that's the one mystery they couldn't
solve she was always peeping Velma
yes I did pull off her mask and it's old
man McNeely the sex offender who runs
like the Haunted Amusement Park
dressed as Velma to hook high school
girls bro
I just thought Shaggy was by because he
just puts everything in his mouth yes
oh but
it's a cartoonist that come out of the
closet Shira is what Daria oh yeah by
the way I might have some inside
information on Francine from Arthur what
I don't know I think sponge they said
SpongeBob is gay but I don't know if
that's true he's probably into weird
stuff though because he's got a lot of
holes he's a very convenient gay sponge
yes
I think Peppermint Patty recently said
she was gay yeah I believe uh Velma and
Patty dated after Velma was dumped by
Anne Heche you know really they just she
just needs to find herself some cartoon
Jesus yes she does that's true yes
right now I'm gonna look for the ghost
he's not there oh bro they hit a lot of
uh they had a lot of old Meats out of
haunted places yes they did it's an old
Haunted Mansion and you're just making a
sandwich right yeah I don't get the
ghost thing are you not sick all the
time I don't understand they are it's to
hide the AIDS yes yeah no she's a
lesbian well no I know come on SpongeBob
just just riddled with it yeah that's
true those aren't those aren't holes uh
all right I'm not even a sponge let's
move on to Elon Musk here uh Elon Musk
has agreed to uh continue now with the
and this isn't necessarily new but
there's some there's some new
developments uh the 44 billion dollar
purchase of and that was the original
price too that's what kind of surprised
us is with the Bots issue we thought
that there would be the deal went deal
fell through we thought okay there would
be sort of scaling back of the price of
negotiation no we're still at 44 billion
dollars and now it looks like it's going
to go through Elon has agreed to
purchase Twitter for that price silicon
Valley's latest soap opera looks like it
might be coming to an end with musk
saying today he's ready to buy but if
musk owns Twitter will it be good for
users and how about for business a
professor of social media says maybe
Twitter might work better operationally
under musk he has he knows how to run
companies and make money Twitter's been
in chaos for a decade cycling through
various CEOs but what about the tone of
a musk run Twitter he's never shied away
from controversy calling the platform's
decision to ban Donald Trump quote
morally wrong and flat out stupid and I
think that statement is morally
simplistic and flat out inaccurate he's
also promised to bring Trump Twitter if
the deal went through here's a random
lady saying something that's
inconsequential in broken news
do yes I think he's wrong thank you what
does this guy on CNN have two abscesses
oh my goodness
what is that
odd face looks like he's in a looks like
he's in a mirror house it looks like if
you it looks like a full bad magazine
when they go up what's his voice like I
would imagine it sounds like this
I cannot find a collar shirt to fit me
with a darn
everything hurts it's a silly News Real
News my point is news isn't real it's
been an illusion for so long I don't
know if you say oh you can't trust the
New Media people you're watching it
they're just they're just showing tweets
and people just saying things I don't
care
I don't care so a couple of things here
question is what's the long what I do
care about is what's the long game right
for Elon Musk uh with Twitter
and I also should know you know I lost
like 10 000 Twitter followers overnight
yeah The Purge happened again it
happened with Ben Shapiro and Matt Walsh
Dave Reuben Tim Poole not to the same
degree remember when Elon Musk announced
he was going to purchase Twitter we
gained hundreds of thousands of
followers over the course of a couple of
weeks right and he actually came out and
he spoke out against the shadow Banning
right yeah throttling and then they said
oh my gosh she's gonna have access to
our books the theory was we don't know
all of a sudden we start gaining all
these followers we were showing up in
people's feeds now with this deal going
through obviously he's made a big stink
about Bots he said it's yeah they've
grossly underestimated the amount of
bots fake accounts looks like the
purchases is is going through and now
accounts are being removed so the point
is he could be calling he could be
calling the shots there but certainly uh
he has influence someone like an Elon
Musk has influence and he has influence
Beyond just owning Twitter uh but even
just what he says about these platforms
you know they have to hop too algorithms
change we don't know exactly what
changed we do know that things changed
twice and the two things that changed
obviously the central concerns that he
expressed were the reasons for that
change yeah absolutely and I really do
hope that he puts Donald Trump back on
the platform yes immediately right and
so we'll see we'll see if the follower
count goes back up because if they did
return to kind of their old ways because
the follower account's kind of leveled
off for a little while and they didn't
really climb as much anymore and so if
they've gone back to their old ways
hopefully this will be the thing that
finally breaks that Trend and Elon can
be like okay let's just people will
follow whoever they want to follow stop
making it to where they can't be seen
right okay well also the the Twitter
stock price you know it it surged yeah
and so that does beg the question okay
the only currency that Twitter really
has and this is something we run into
with YouTube by the way their currencies
their their user base right A lot of
these New Media companies these social
media companies they had a tough time
monetizing I don't even know if YouTube
has yet to make a dime I know for years
they didn't maybe they have now so the
currency is eyeballs and ears and so
this is the market responding they
obviously would believe we're all making
the presumption that Elon Musk would be
more uh supportive of an open platform
so in other words a Speculator saying
hey that'll be good for this company
whose currencies eyeballs what does that
mean they mean that means that they're
saying they're making an inference right
they're saying okay so if Elon Musk
purchases Twitter which is not worth all
that much it's been a shitty platform
for a very long time dead last when
we're talking about the big arms race
for for social media if he ends up
taking control and he allows for more
it'll actually make the platform more
valuable because more people were going
to be will want to be there when you
hear the argument in media it's well
should they be doing more to remove
people and make it safer or should they
be doing less and make well guess what
the market has spoken doing less
allowing more voices is better for these
companies
that's these people have nothing other
than a financial interest in trying to
determine where this is going to go Elon
Musk has said I want this to be more
open platform I think there's two
there's not enough transparency there's
too much Shadow Banning throttling I
think there are too many Bots and then
when we find out okay Elon Musk is going
to be in charge of Twitter so you can
make the inference he's most likely
going to make it a more open platform
speculators say oh maybe Twitter has a
shot yeah that's a silver lining that
means more speech is better yeah
absolutely and also these big banks that
joined in like a lot of this funding is
coming from Big Banks except for the one
that I think Twitter was currently using
they were the only people left out the
transaction I'm not kidding Elon Musk
has a little bit of Donald Trump in him
where he's like all right we're gonna
take every big Bank out there except for
you the one that's currently working
with Twitter right it's like oh okay
thanks a lot listen will all the banks
who will be involved with this new
purchase step forward you that's the
best
oh the cabinet Banks you stay back I'm
saying that's what Donald Trump would do
yeah well I mean you know I think the
bigger the broader Point here is that
obviously there's some value in buying a
company right so the big time you know
big sorry big picture issue is if you
see a company and you say okay I like
what they have I can make it better I
can do it in a way that they're not
doing it right now I'm not just
necessarily going to kind of
incrementally improve the platform I can
take it and make it something better
right I think that's what Elon is going
after and we have some information about
his relationship uh with the the before
that you know what else is Big Time
important hit the like button that's
what helps us by the way you're right
every little time you hit the like
button okay uh a a YouTube uh a YouTube
Demon Angel loses its wings that's true
they rip them off yeah there you go like
a Mayflower yes a blue-haired lesbian
becomes a blonde again yes they hate it
they hate it so hit like uh and you were
you had some information this you had
some insight yeah so it's really
interesting so some of the court
documents about this and that's that's
come forward because of the lawsuit make
it not boring Twitter yeah saying that
they were going to back out of the deal
is going to back out of the deal they
actually show a relationship between
Jack Dorsey and Elon Musk and so we've
got some tweets on April 26th
um did Jack Dorsey try and sell him
Wilson he did not yeah he wanted to hold
on to them
yes a new platform is needed it can't be
a company that is why I left and so Elon
responded to it basically saying okay
what should it look like and Dorsey said
I believe it should be an open source
protocol otherwise we have surface area
interesting point here surface area that
governments and advertisers will try to
influence and control Jack dorsey's not
for that right in this comment he's not
for the government stepping in and
saying what you can and can't do he's
not for advertisers directing you and
it's what I've been saying forever we've
been saying forever and in front of the
cameras Jack dress has been saying no
right and now behind the posturing I
think I received three or four more
notifications from Twitter this week
that I was in violation of German law
because of speech still so how can you
be a business that's based in the United
States and maybe hold into German are
you beholden to Chinese you know Chinese
speech laws this this is the issue right
and Jack Dorsey knows it's a problem but
in front of the scenes I bet you if you
were to talk with a bunch of Hollywood
producers too they're like yeah we had
to change Red Dawn from China to North
Korea this is a complete horse crap but
we have to appease these guys because
it's a market that's assuming Jack
Dorsey has to do behind closed doors
just from a business perspective he gets
it it's not good yeah absolutely and
elon's a dreamer man he's trying to come
up with these like crazy awesome ideas
for the world sometimes obviously he
benefits from a lot of these things too
but he said here super interesting idea
and then Jack Dorsey tells him he's off
of the Twitter board and a little while
I can do this work and fix our mistakes
Twitter started his protocol it should
have never been a company that was the
original sin and then Elon comes in and
says I'd like to help if I'm able to so
it's really interesting to see these two
guys that would be the perfect
combination Elon Musk and Jack Dorsey
both kind of moving in the same
direction Elon maintained ownership in
x.com after the PayPal merger after he
left he kept that with him right he
always loved having that company he
wanted to be like just so you know it's
like the everything app right and so
that's what he tweeted out uh saying
that this acquisition was an accelerant
for that maybe giving us a little bit of
a glimpse as to why he thought Twitter
was a good purchase in the first place
it could be just a technology base it
could be something that he's like I can
take what they have and make it so much
more than it currently is and then it's
worth a multiple right what he bought it
for right I don't trust Jack Dorsey you
don't trust Jack no I don't know I don't
either why would I no why would why are
you surprised by that have you we just
read privacy is this real life it seems
like this guy is this happening right
now on the right side of this you're
surprised I don't trust you absolutely
surprised every time he's interviewed
he's in a suit with ear spreaders like
he's in court well I don't trust that he
like gays gross crits yeah but I'm just
well yeah like a rich
yeah me too yeah he's got all of his
yeah I'm not going to say it we'll
probably be bad but no I I he said the
right things here if he's not just
people here and this is if he was listen
if you are the CEO of this company he's
also the CEO of square he has a
responsibility to those companies
otherwise he gets removed from being CEO
and can't do anything about it right
yeah so if he had to posture I don't
agree with it but I understand it if now
he's saying I want to correct the
Original Sin Fine show me that you
actually mean it but it's it gives me
some hope you're right I could just be
jealous because I put all my investments
in trapezoid that's true was that a
thing I prefer guns
what do you think look comment below you
trust the Jack Dorsey thing I do like
this tanking
oh damn you oblong
cuts to a guy's face is just what you
without naming names Dave you and I know
this yes a lot of people who host these
uh podcasts even and certainly a lot of
people in the entertainment industry
they are far more conservative behind
the scenes of course than they let on
yes even people who are like I'm sort of
middle of the Centrist middle of the
road people and I would never out them
but behind the scenes you realize how
right-wing they're because what happens
is they start with speech they start
with supporting the idea of freedom and
then the more successful they become
they realize oh wait a second there is a
boys club and they want to take all of
my money so now they become conservative
fiscally and then the longer they go you
realize you can't really separate you
can't separate these things when I see
comedians we'll talk about the storm
like Bill Burr saying what's wrong with
socialism
well there's you can't separate a
socialist government from every single
government that is even full-on
socialist moderate socialist Nordic
socialist model European socialism and a
complete control over your speech and
autonomy you can't separate it and so
people who maybe present themselves
ascentra they are far more right-wing
lines I run into it all the time and
they say you know I'm just I gotta play
ball yeah and the minute they start
leaning to the right like Elon has here
he's he started leaning to the right and
all of a sudden he has come under heavy
fire from everyone I lean right in every
facet I even you know
every every guy knows you have to pick a
side where you go do you go left you go
right you don't have to pick a side you
do well like Dave you go left you go
right I go right yeah I go right what
did you just go straight forward you
can't go straight forward when you sit
down and the genes become a seam it's
like a high tension cable wire
build Hondas all day I just sort of Z
cavarichi so I have plenty of room I
don't know what that means okay Hammer
pants
I don't know that's what they were
called well that was like the because
these are like that can't touch this you
can't I got plenty of room to touch this
that's like him with all of his
previously hard assets
yep oops
So speaking we're going to get to the
nordstream issue okay and that's going
to take a little bit of time so I I just
want to let you know we're not going to
get too crazy nerdy but I do want to
give you the ins and outs and the
potential players there but before that
I do want to take a Victory lap here
I have been trying to get banned from
Tick Tock since February of 2022 uh
because it's run by communist bastards
now they had banned me before and then
they decided they weren't going to bend
it was just too much work I hate having
to upload crap to all these different
places and their guidelines are
incredibly strict so they wouldn't ban
us when we were doing we did the ban ban
me from Tick Tock segment right for a
long time if you remember they never
banned us right hard now here's my
theory they banned us just two days ago
or three days ago yeah in the dead of
night I think they deliberately avoided
Banning us when we were saying please
ban us because they realize the Optics
would look bad like well okay hold on he
criticized the Chinese Communist Chinese
government he said Banis we ban him
that's going to look bad so they waited
until it died down and then they banned
us recently I don't care thank you
finally so uh just so we put a close to
this chapter mission accomplished with
all of this screw the CCP screw XI
xingping and Tick Tock well at least my
Tick Tock time to close
I can't good conscious remain on the
platform on Tick Tock I've already been
banned like three times I was going to
manually delete tick tock was the plan
like on my phone go look and then I
realized wait a second I don't need to
do that you can have much I can just say
I can just say true things okay all
right let's try this for tick tock miles
Great Leap Forward led to the death of
45 million Chinese citizens a Xi Jinping
plagiarized uh your doctoral thesis on
June 4th 1989 the CCP murdered thousands
of protesters at the Tiananmen Square
the nine dash line isn't real
[Music]
ending and beginning now
time to close
it's time to go to places where you go
end it for me mercy come on
I don't want to have to upload stuff to
your platform anymore but I'm not
South China I'm talking I'm talking to
you not him China you I think all of us
can say this in Unity on the count of
three three two okay CCP oh bother
foreign
I don't know how to say thank you in
Chinese how do you say
in one of the Chinese is in Mandarin
um yeah not the one that used in Hong
Kong I don't know that's Cantonese I
know Mandarin Cantonese just so people
don't go oh you can do anything the
point is I'm trying to be offensive yeah
you bow do you bow already a verb I
don't know if you bow and Chen do you
bow in China I feel like you bow they
hit you over the head and put you in a
uyghur camp that's true
about
that's how you say thank you
I do know Japanese because of remember
the big bird movie yeah when we were
kids we would say dead put on Big Bird
turns blue because they like they beat
him like he's an elephant in a circus
and he turns blue and what was it it was
a it was uh
uh sorry that was that was thank you in
Chinese yeah let me hear it I caught
that
[Laughter]
thank you that's my favorite one but one
two three means
if someone find the the the Japanese
song from uh I haven't heard it in years
it's good something is good morning
that's my favorite one but one two three
I'm pretty close friends are saying in
the Big Bird he's like itchini sun and
then he gets you know like I don't know
Oscar tried to sell him some crack I
don't remember
stepping over homeless people get it
together Grouch
[Laughter]
Snuffaluffagus I'm sick bird I want some
smack Birds brought to you by the letter
e his pupils just
yeah maybe if you just gave him some
painkillers you'd be like not that
grouchy he's like oh man yeah that's
pretty good man not to mention those
Muppets who clearly had a stroke where
the only word they can remember is yep
yeah there's a lot of going on in Sesame
Street that I think is behind closed
doors
yep can you say anything else yep yep
yep oh it's stroke Muppet oh he's fun
yeah that's really just a stroke they
can only say yep and I can say this my
grandfather had a stroke he could only
say yes he couldn't say no but he could
sing happy birthday every single year to
my dad really yeah not to put a damper
on it but it's a different side of the
brain my point is Sesame Street is awful
and uh a lot of them are likely
pedophiles allegedly so Elmo
allegedly
I have a story about that I don't know
if we'll get banned for you know that
guy Elmo he had he said he had
consensual relationships okay look I'm
just sorry today is one of those days
I'm just just go with me here you the
guy do the Elmo voice right he had a
consent he claimed it was consensual
sexual relationship with young men right
while he was married
the allegations there were many were
that these people were under age like 16
years old yeah okay here's the thing
they fired him at Sesame Street
or he resigned but if you go and watch
The Dark Crystal uh making of the show
he's there
really he's there puppeteering yeah so
in other words it was clearly just for
show so whether he did it or not he
obviously had done something or the
situation was untenable where they
wanted him to resign publicly but behind
the scenes if you guys have watched the
dark that's not really a great series
just so you know it doesn't really do
the film justice but the making of
documentary you can see that alleged
pedophile Elmo puppeteer right there and
at one point I swear to you he almost
looks away from the camera like they're
showing look this is how we do it he's
like oh
oh that's crazy I just thought it was
that's I thought it was crappy why risk
it why risk it why have him involved
with anything that has to do with
children are you old enough to drive
that makes almost sad
you page down
no means no and well no means yeah
five knows and a Yes means we're doing
this
Emma's soft yes little little uh wire
moves the handle
[Applause]
not there you hold the puppet do you
know
Elmo's real no it's don't tell
[Laughter]
a picture of your dog tied up in his
closet
Elmo doesn't want to hurt your dog give
me camo sad but I'm just latex
take me down to Sesame Street
oh that's you by the letter s
iced tea comes in
you you're a pedophile Elmo
I almost Punchy wow
that's true
[Laughter]
icing her eyes I always said it just
because he did the average he did the
advertisements against domestic abuse
domestic abuse is bad it's bad take it
from this [ __ ]
I got sentenced to four commercials
I gotta do cars out he has a pokey stick
he's picking up trash
stop eating your [ __ ] all right
speaking of tiny free Elmo condoms
[Laughter]
it's ribbed felt yeah
all right all right I gotta get to the
North Street I know you probably don't
care about it but here's the macro point
that I want to make and we'll get to
what's happened with the Nordstrom and
people have different suspicions I want
to be clear we don't have all of the
answers anyone who tells you they have
all the answers is lying I do have my
suspicions Gerald has his suspicions and
all references are available at ladder
with credit.com I try and tell you if
I'm making an inference or if I'm making
a guess we are putting together some
guesswork today because the information
is just hitting you uh constantly
there's no way around it I was going to
say something else about Elmo but now I
lost it okay
so let me let me start with this uh
a big problem here that we're dealing
with when we're talking about none of
this should matter as it relates to the
United States Nordstrom
because we shouldn't be dependent on
anybody and I'll get to that back in a
second you know what the left believe
the left understands it's nationalism is
good for the environment let me give you
an analogy before I get to that you know
how the left knows this is the case uh
homesteading right living off the grid
well why can you be more green why can
you be more effective and you know the
idea is that you'll have less waste less
waste that you'll be more efficient with
your energy why can you do that if you
have your own individual generator power
Oh you mean because the municipal
government doesn't know how to provide
energy for you and how to handle your
waste better than you would if left to
make your own decisions let's just
expand that to National borders of
course the United States would know
better how to provide for our own energy
than Saudi Arabia then for many European
countries of course Russia China take
your pick of course we would we should
all be responsible for our own energy in
the perfect world if we could be the
good news in the United States we
absolutely can be we choose not to be
and so we are beholden to these nations
uh who have no APA standards who
couldn't give a rat's ass about
protecting the environment and also we
have to transport Energy across the
ocean where there are a countless number
of spills and I don't know if you know
this
requires energy to run boats so that's
to set this up now we'll go to Nordstrom
okay last week Nordstrom one and two you
know they were both seemingly sabotaged
so uh my question to you is who do you
think sabotage Nordstrom before we get
into this now
today right now Joe Biden former Vice
President Joe Biden now is talking tough
and blaming Putin and the Russians
it was a deliberate Act of sabotage
and now the Russians are pumping Out
disinformation Lines we work with our
allies to get to the bottom exactly what
it precisely would happen
and as in my direction have already
begun to help our allies enhance the
protection of this critical
infrastructure Sexton was a mildest
songs
foreign
is talking tough you know on Putin right
now which I don't have a problem with
I think Putin's a prick just to be clear
none of this is Russian uh apologetics
if that's the term that I can use it
because you'll be accused of it yes
you'll be accused of it so people have
said that there are conspiracies
floating around
that the United States or former Vice
President Joe Biden himself may be
directly involved with the sabotage
that's a conspiracy but you may behold
some of those conspiratorial views
because then not too long ago former
Vice President Joe Biden said he might
do this to nordstream too if uh if
Russia invades that means tanks or
troops crossing the uh the the Border
thanks for the definition of invades
again then uh there will be uh we there
will be no longer on North stream too we
we will bring an end to it
seems pretty clear what how would you
how will you do that oh clarify
exactly since the project and control of
the project is within Germany's control
we will I promise you we'll be able to
do it yeah
what are you Alex Jones
yeah we just think that why what would
what how what could possibly make you
think that former Vice President Joe
Biden would have a vested interest in
ending nordstream
aside from he said it
right it's true also sir why uh we're in
a kind of a dim room why are you
squinting like you're looking into the
sun right sir is that a healthy thing
no it's not I'm horribly unhealthy no no
so there's Joe Biden yeah well seeing
all these Stars right I smell burnt
toast I taste pennies oh here's what
it's not I know what you could say
former Vice President Joe Biden talk
stuff he's an idiot sure sorry respect
the office he's an idiot so uh here's
what the under Secretary of State uh for
political Affairs Victoria Newland
had to say about not just Joe Biden
talking tough about nordstream 2. in
December
as we discussed last night in some
detail what we are talking about would
amount to essentially isolating Russia
completely from the Global Financial
system with all of the Fallout that that
would entail for Russian business for
the Russian people for their ability to
to work and travel and trade one thing
that I believe certainly the center
Foreign Relations Committee is pretty
unified on it may not be unanimous was
our support for sanctions against
Nordstrom II pipeline that I think we
are all many of us were very
disappointed that those sanctions were
not fully implemented and the
construction continued I certainly hope
that the center Foreign Relations
Committee would take up
legislation to go beyond just suspending
it but from ending it permanently okay
so you have them okay ending at
permanently that's kind of vague then
you have Joe Biden twice saying we will
put an end to it we have our ways trust
me we can do it now
um let me clear about a couple things
something here is sort of a macro point
do you notice when people say oh well
cancel culture isn't a thing you're not
the government's not arresting you now
of course in every country that's not
the United States you are arrested for
what you say but notice that even when
we're talking about internationally
crippling crippling Russia
we're not just saying nuke them they're
saying cut off their ability to make a
living that's what happens to all of you
if you engage in wrong think so when
people say well that's not censorship if
the government if the FBI at the CIA if
you're audited by the IRS in 80 000 new
agents if we put pressure on private
companies like jensaki did calling for
Spotify to engage in more censorship in
all of social media where they host
these meetings that's not government
censorship
no no we're just going to remove your
ability to make a living that's exactly
what they do internationally that's the
most effective tool it is you realize
wars were fought just over basic
territory over Farmland you don't think
that people would have thought it
wouldn't have been a war over the
ability to make a living because the
government can pinch that valve entirely
so just just keep that in mind the next
time people say it's not a First
Amendment issue all that's at stake is
your livelihood so we'll get to there's
Russia there's Ukraine there's the
United States potentially who could have
done this there are a lot of
conspiracies around
um there's also another one that uh
honestly I I do think given the recent
evidence that we have yeah there's
another actor at play and uh it could
just be a glorified ad for Seagal's new
film so that is something that yeah
laughs
I knew it under scene when I understand
he's like where's the throat yes
undeadly water yes
this is so terrible down below
under the laws
you would name it that'd be like when I
take him at energy pipelines ah bad
things happen was he sitting in that yes
of course he can't stand anymore
I didn't see that hey good job
yeah because the last eight movies he's
made he's like I'll be sitting the whole
time yes exactly I look more powerful
his stunt double is more unrealistic
than when the Power Rangers would all
turn into like you know 12 year old
Japanese gymnasts yeah
double is uh you just have to stand for
Mr Seagal yes just a fat guy in a
wheelchair
it's the Hologram of Larry Flint yeah
all right
so we have to ask ourselves okay what
exactly has happened with the nursing
pipelines okay first really quickly
let's take a look at the pipelines uh
they weren't from Russia under the
Baltic Sea to Germany okay property of a
Russian state-owned Energy company uh
gas prom and of course that's why Putin
is one of the wealthiest people in the
world it's all completely Illustrated he
stole it yeah I don't think that these
people should be included in the
wealthiest people uh on the planet list
whether it's him whether it's Saudi
Arabian oil Sheiks or people who are
born into it people who took it from
their P I don't think that that should
be included alongside people like Bill
Gates Mark Zuckerberg uh Jeff Bezos even
though I don't like those people I think
there's a difference between actually
earning your money versus stealing it
okay so September 26th
three separate leaks Nordstrom one and
two right these are recorded just for
those of you who don't know here is
exactly what it looked like
[Applause]
[Music]
more than the leak I did that
let's go
[Applause]
very dramatic yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so we were kind of going through
this this morning like I said this is a
bit of a discussion we have to go
through what would be the motivations
for Russia for Ukraine for the United
States okay what would be Russia's
motivation for sabotage and uh by the
way I can hit the like button helps the
algorithm I would really like to hear
what you think
I'm kind of 60 40. remember last week we
were talking about the nukes same kind
of thing
I don't think it's completely out of the
realm of possibility that the United
States has played a role in this right
not saying they sent in you know Jesse
Ventura with the underwater demolitions
unit to to you know prick the pipeline
but I think that there could have been
some shots call from the United States
so what would be Russia's motivation for
the sabotage okay well first off 35 of
all EU gas comes from Russia okay
uh here would be maybe one reason
Germany uh they already froze the
Nordstrom 2 project two days before
Russia invaded Ukraine Russia had
stopped all the gas flows through
nordstream one right so that was that
was The Leverage right that was Russia's
leveraging saying okay well we're not
going to send any gas to you which
prompted the entire EU to basically say
get ready for a very hard winter right
right make sure you guys save as much as
you can on energy because we might not
have any okay William or Aiden he's in
he was in Paris nothing like any
original stereotype he was in Paris and
he was saying it's so cold they would
they shut off they shut off the heat so
I knew they were shutting off water
heaters in Paris or sorry in France for
certain times a day but apparently there
might actually be certain city-wide
mandates to shut off oh there aren't
yeah yeah absolutely yeah because it's I
mean it's gonna get really really cold
obviously right a lot of those places
and so they're saying all right well if
we're not gonna have gas you're not
gonna have any options you have to burn
by God we're gonna have to burn wood
wouldn't it be great if that giant
nuclear plant wasn't closed down last
month and so basically the European
Union right the EU all these countries
are saying like Russia you better not
and then they go out in public and say
by the way we are going to move off uh
we're no longer going to use Russian gas
or Russian energy and then oh so they
shouldn't affect you they go no no hey
we said we would move off Russian energy
eventually yes one of these days because
right now Russia's saying okay there's
no time like the present yeah right
that's their leverage right there
because you can't threaten the country
right that way to try and [ __ ] them
economically and not expect some
ramifications that's a strong case for
why Russia might have done this right so
the in Russia is in a position
especially Putin right now where he's
losing power he's losing his grip on his
citizens because they don't want to be
fighting in this war and they certainly
don't want to go to full-scale
mobilization they don't believe in it
that much they're not defending their
Homeland they're invading another
country right right so in his mind if
the the economics have been removed from
the situation already
he can do this and then say the West has
attacked us right right so that's a bit
it's a stretch this is all conjecture
what you're saying so hold on just to be
clear you're being a little bit
convoluted what you're what you're
saying because we talked about this
before I think what you're trying to say
is he could have sabotaged it and wants
to blame it correct on the west
so that he can say look at what they're
doing look they look at the evil devil
right yeah but there's a two-pronged uh
two-pronged benefit there for them is
they also get to harm the rest of Europe
because they shut off their energy yeah
they shut off their energy and say fine
if you want to be independent from us
then we'll we'll see how you like that
during the winter right so it's like now
the Ukraine the Ukrainian people would
also kind of benefit from this if if
Russia if is blamed for this or if the
United States is blamed for this either
way they kind of win right right because
if they're the ones that did it I don't
know if they have the capacity to do it
or the wherewithal but if they did it
they now have pitted two of their kind
of you know big players against each
other right so the United States is more
apt to jump in and say oh no no we're
going to go and and do more against
Russia so we're going to help Ukraine
further which Joe Biden just I think
sent several hundred million more in
arms to Ukraine and signed that into uh
money well spent last week something
like that right so the other thing to
keep in mind too is that Russia knew
that their hold on the the country was
actually going to go away even further
because they had just completed a Baltic
pipeline to go into Poland start taking
some of this demand away from Russia
right so they were they were kind of
towards the end of that game anyway
right so this is basically all right
Europe go ahead go ahead and do it
without us and they get to say well look
if the Americans did this and harm the
pipeline look how bad that imagine if we
did it ourselves which we did not do
we like long tests this time we did not
do it is America but we could do we
didn't do but with facilities but we
didn't but we could be much worse for
you that's what they're trying to do now
what would be America's motivation for
the sabotage here again there's
speculation okay here's one gas you know
the gas from Russia to Europe right it's
the it really is the only source of
revenue for Moscow it's the primary
source it is the driver yeah if it goes
away this nation ceases to be nordstream
two alone you're talking about tens of
billions of of Euros uh something else
another reason these pipelines they
bypass Eastern Europe right they take
away revenue from countries like Ukraine
right
I think it's like three billion dollars
a year right from Ukraine yeah that's
also by the way that's the uh that's the
speaking fee for uh zielinski no no
that's the private stand-up performance
yes yes did I show you the bit where
he's playing the piano with his penis
I'm sorry no yeah guys you can find that
uh Sarah sent us an email she found that
we can run it later where he's but it's
so I'm not excited so over the top this
is a stand-up it's what you would expect
from awful Eastern Europeans okay yeah
he's there behind the piano going like
and moving his hands like see it's like
I'm doing it with my with my junk see so
it's better than any speech Biden has
given yes
if he would have just answered every
question by playing the piano with this
dong you'd be like oh wow all right I
think I'd vote for him yeah
by the way here's a that is amazing oh
we'll find I'll find it you didn't see
this yeah no I know I did I went down
the rabbit hole of zielinski stand up
after we talked about it I thought it
would just be the one clip nope there's
more oh dear it was like Dancing with
the Stars was like it was like dancing
with zielinski like he was on every
reality show there's so much that exists
of awful we have it there's so many
different shows and all this do we have
it yeah we have it do you want to do it
let's do it okay so by the way this is
I don't even know how to set like I said
the darling they're just two awful
places Russia because of the human
rights violations right because of the
fact that they oppress their people
because Putin is wealthy through
ill-gotten gain and then Ukraine because
they let this [ __ ] lead them
and their pants are down around their
ankles by the way
that's enough
those guys are laughing because they'll
get shot if they don't
I uh
I rarely use the term offensive
I had a loss for words
oh your face on this is hilarious
um
yeah you know it's crazy they were
really doing it
yeah I don't think they're really doing
it he would have been in a minor case
there's a real talent that's true
one was playing the whites yes
what a stupid imagine what he did to the
toy store with a big one and big piano
like a big yeah so
streaks slip and slides it he's just
doing it the same way
it's just both of them Robert loggia's
old balls
look at the time one spends writing to
craft a joke and he's like I could just
out of sync fake slam my wiener on a
piano yeah and there's somebody else
who's like can I do that with you yes
yeah this yeah someone's there's some
agent like no no what you got here is
it why would you do it
just you I can make two stars two
penises is always better than one yes
like Martin and Lewis okay
oh boy
or Louis and Clark oh it is your dick
needs to be on those Ivory Keys No
in case he got him on that one all right
sorry what it's such a boring topic
that's when you test stickle to the
ivories
ah son of a gun
I don't even know if you guys are
tracking no no no I I call what you said
and I'm aware that it's now son but oh
okay thank you it's not even is by the
way they're not even in sync like there
was this funny act in Montreal Just For
Last we see all these weird comedy
accidents not the same thing where these
guys were on stage completely naked and
they just each had like a balloon and as
a balloons would deflate they would pass
them so you never actually saw anything
yeah but this was brilliantly
choreographed where you every time you
thought oh my gosh there's going to be
full frontal nudity they did something
that was funny and they would do it as a
troop like okay it's different it's
weird but I mean compared to like what
you might in France which is you know
some clown in a paper mache hat and they
laughed their ass off like okay this is
decent comedy coming out of Europe
that is just lazy penis piano playing
back to North stream Columbia Professor
Jeffrey Sachs had this to say where he
was making the case that the and Beyond
Joe Biden said he might do it that the
United States is at fault
did you have of that
well first of all there's direct radar
evidence that U.S helicopters military
helicopters that are normally based in
Gdansk were circling over this area we
also had the threats from the United
States earlier in this year that one way
or another we are going to end Nordstrom
we also have a remarkable statement by
secretary blinken last Friday in a press
conference he says this is also a
tremendous opportunity it's a strange
way to it's asari it's a strange way to
talk if you're worried about the piracy
on International infrastructure of vital
significance so I know this runs counter
to our narrative it runs you're not
allowed to say these things uh in in the
west but the fact of the matter is all
over the world when I talk to people
they think the U.S did thank you
Napoleon Dynamite's Uncle now he's a
crazy he's one of those crazy conspiracy
theorists who's a professor at Columbia
we also have the Polish uh mp uh former
uh foreign minister uh radek Sikorski
thank the United States on Twitter
saying thank you USA now that doesn't
mean that it's true it just means that
there's enough smoke there where a
significant number of players
internationally believe there could be
fire my only point is this don't allow
people to tell you that you're a crazy
conspiracy theorist if you think ah you
know what I think the United States may
be involved here yeah because that's
what the media is trying to memory hole
what Biden said right and it's
incredibly Reckless for the
administration to say stuff like that
they like they said earlier and also we
didn't play one of the clips from
Victoria Newland she actually went
further and said that she would that we
would end it right there was a more
precise clip at a briefing that she was
giving and people look at her and go oh
she's the one that pushed for the
Ukrainian government to be overthrown in
2014 she's the one that pushed for the
Iraq War I'm starting to see a little
bit of a trend here with this Warhawk
essentially going out there and pushing
so if Biden is taking instructions from
anybody that has anything to do with her
it's very likely that that could have
happened right and it's very dangerous
for the administration to be so obvious
with it if they're going to do this at
some point down the road you send a memo
out or something you that you you talk
to everybody so there's no paper tone
just say don't say anything stupid like
we will end it right I didn't want to
cut you off because you're making a good
point and I assume this will be clipped
for Crowder bits but I think what you're
what you're saying is she can't be
trusted because she's a [ __ ] I didn't
say those words
[Music]
comment below
five seconds
all right
don't don't I want to see if people get
it I don't know it
that's a fantastic one do you know the
one I do
the tuba which we can't say anymore is
one of the funniest things that's ever
been on the internet okay so here's
something else that I want you to sort
of focus on this this should be
highlighting I don't want to say should
to me this does highlight something more
important and I will say emphatically ah
you shouldn't speak in absolute uh green
energy policies and certainly how we
pursue them here in the United States
it's we all know that it's horrible
economically we all know that it's
deadly for human beings right because as
Energy prices go up you know I think
right now it's threes at 370 something
for gas across the country significantly
less expensive about to go out by the
way OPEC just raised it right that's
about to go up so in Michigan it's not
even hit close to that I was there
recently what is it in Michigan it's
like four really yeah yeah and then it
was like almost still five something for
premium I've noticed the Gap in Michigan
and it didn't used to be as severe
between Michigan and Texas I would have
to look at sort of State policies and
why that is if Texas was you know if
Texas was like when Donald Trump was
President it was like a buck 89 in
Michigan it was like maybe like a buck
99 yeah now it's a huge gap it's almost
like California like 30 cents right and
keep in mind for you that's inconvenient
and it sucks and for you if it could be
really difficult and cut into your
bottom line combined with the other
inflation that you see at the grocery
store that you see everywhere right that
being said do count your blessings
because for people in third world
countries it's deadly they die
they die if they can't afford energy so
when I say that green policies are worse
for the environment I'm separating that
we all know beyond any shadow of a doubt
economically it is crippling we all know
that it kills millions of people right
for every there's a there are these
tables that exist I don't have them in
front of me where for every dollar the
price of uh of gas goes up or the price
per barrel goes up how many people lose
their lives because they're not able to
whether it's Heat their homes whether
it's cook their food so let's separate
that just on the environmental impact
green policies are a net negative now
remember this and this this is
highlighted with Nordstrom
2018 Donald Trump warned
the Europeans about being dependent on
what on What
and by the way to give Mitt Romney
credit and I really hate to do that I
know remember back in the debates we
talked about the problem with Russia and
remember what Barack Obama said yeah the
1980s are calling they want your foreign
policy but yep he said exactly yeah I
was going to do it
[Laughter]
he said that in the debates and they're
the ones vilifying Russia again keep in
mind the the Republicans conservatives
have been presenting very logical right
very reasonable arguments hey there's
actually a problem with dependence on
Russian energy that's just
fear-mongering uh you know Red Dawn
called they want they want you to be uh
in their casting call whatever the hell
it is that he said
and then they go Russia's evil whereas
we were saying well regardless of
whether Russia is evil or not we're not
calling me we just shouldn't be
dependent in Europe is it Europe has a
problem being beholden to a very
unstable country so Donald Trump in 2018
warned the Europeans about being
dependent on Russian energy now if you
don't remember the reaction it's not
that they said well maybe we disagree
the Germans
arguably most affected by this right now
the Germans laughed at him publicly
here's a refresher Germany will become
totally dependent
on Russian energy
if it does not immediately change course
here in the Western Hemisphere we are
committed
to maintaining our independence from the
encroachment
of expansionist foreign
policy of our country since President
Monroe all of those people have a
lifetime of experience and about this
American sick he's
for you and by the way
let's bring up overlay and here all
reference available up the 40s right yes
people on vacation
uh before we get to uh the other issues
here keep in mind 2018 that was the
first time the United States became a
net exporter of oil in the fine fuel
refined fuels in decades in decades so
Donald Trump said you guys need to
change your dependency here this is
going to be a problem for you and for
the first time made it so that we were
actually a net exporter which I would
argue better for the world if the world
was able to get gas or the world's able
to get oil whatever form of energy from
us better than getting it from Russia so
here's the issue being dependent on
energy from Russia forces you to play
ball with not only countries not only
evil people who don't give a [ __ ] about
human rights but they also don't care
about the environment to be clear yeah
and we don't need to be dependent on
them at all America right now and we've
gotten into the numbers where Joe Biden
people say well actually he's allowed
for more Drilling in federal land that's
because he ended a bunch of leases and
then he opened up some more after Donald
Trump right we
go back and you go watch that segment
I'm not going to spend that takes an
hour in and of itself here's the here's
the point America has enough natural gas
to feed our demand to supply our
domestic demand for at least 98 years
wow and in an environment uh
environmentally conscious way of
removing it yes yeah
alternative
and so well we can't do that so what do
we do
well we've banned we've banned uh some
of the fracking we've banned some of the
offshore drilling so where are we
getting right now we need to enter where
are we
um Saudi Arabia oh that's better for the
environment Venezuela oh that's better
for the people of Venezuela that are
still not able to have food also again
We're a nation of people though we've
just we buy slave made products all over
the country in the most horrible ways
ever and we just don't do it here and we
think that's okay well then we virtue
signal like ah you should definitely
treat people better and they need 25 an
hour to be able to work okay what are
you saying to the people over in China
NBA oh what about them but we're just
going to go over there to get the stuff
but yeah I mean as long as it's over
here and by the way you can't blame all
the business owners because
unfortunately it's not cost effective
you can't even be sustainable to build a
lot of these uh things in the United
States why because of the taxes because
of the red tape because of the
regulations isn't there a middle ground
where there are no regulations in slave
labor in China versus I believe now
since it's gone back up the highest if
not top two High highest corporate tax
rate in the industrialized world
including a lot of the European
socialist countries that make it
impossible to run a business for us to
be able to manufacture and create our
our or at least use we can't use our raw
materials in a lot of ways because it's
bad for the environment so so a business
owner has to go and get something done
it's not his fault it is your
government's fault so we have enough uh
gas to feed for 98 years okay that's
from the United States Department of
energy now the United States also has
more oil reserves than any country in
the world
a lot of people don't know that you
think Saudi Arabia right maybe you think
Venezuela United States has more
we just don't use all of it so we get it
from those countries
and by the way not only is it dirty and
corrupt right the Nordstrom incident
could be the single largest methane
release ever
when Joe Biden gives a press conference
and by the way the largest the largest
tanker spill ever was uh the Atlantic
Empress that's right it was it was a
Greek ship it was going from Saudi
Arabia to Texas in 2021 alone more than
10 000 tons of oil were spilled by
tankers oil tankers they make up 13
percent of Maritime emissions 114
million tons of CO2 annually from
transporting energy countries like
Russia Ukraine energy companies right
they prop up these corrupt it it just
props up these oligarchies this is you
have several it's worse for the
environment there are more spills there
are more CO2 emissions more methane
emissions
and you're supporting the oligarchies
who then get the champion themselves I'm
one of the wealthiest men in the country
he should be poor and we should use our
own energy why if only
to save the environment yeah and if you
guys really do hate places like Saudi
Arabia and you want to make sure that
those people don't stay in power you
hate places like Russia that not not the
people of the countries but the leaders
of those countries why do you continue
to say that we should buy oil from them
and not do it here they they certainly
we've told you they don't have the same
kind of Standards but you're also
feeding their country you're basically
saying you get to stay in power because
you get enough money to make sure your
people don't overthrow you that's
essentially what's going on in Saudi
Arabia right now without all that money
there's no way people take any kind of
subjugation if you don't have any kind
of carrot if it's just all stick
eventually it goes away right yeah for
sure yeah they would go back to the Dark
Ages
or be forced to change and right now and
I kind of bumbled over this but they
just cut oil production OPEC has power
over us because they're like oh well we
don't like the price of oil right now so
we're going to cut production by two
million barrels per day not a small
thing Joe Biden has taken the United
States oil reserves to the lowest in 40
years just to try and win an election to
make sure gas prices aren't too high
right that's the only reason he's done
it right no you're absolutely right and
this is just one of the again crippling
economically it kills people it's not
that I'm anti-environment I'm I'm I'm
pro-human being that's what it is
and ultimately modern environmentalism
whether it's a five-page green New Deal
that takes over whatever is four-fifths
of the economy go I read the entire
green New Deal you can watch it on
YouTube from from cover to cover all
every single word it took me 16 minutes
to read it's it's religion it's religion
and you worship Gaia you worship earth
right that's just your God it's just
some it's just a new form of of
pantheistic paganism effectively and
it's worse for the environment that's
why there's no logic to it logic would
say okay look sure we would love to we
would love to move to quote unquote
renewable while not a while not allowing
nuclear and by the way every country if
everyone just embraced for example
nuclear energy
every country could Supply themselves
yeah we're we would no longer have to do
the international politicking let me ask
you this when have you ever felt
or when have you felt uh in a
negotiating
agreement to be in Greater control and
this is real I'd like you to comment
below and you can hit the like button it
always helps with the algorithm that
YouTube hates
[Music]
um
let's say I don't know maybe you went to
go buy a car maybe you want to go buy a
house you ever been in a negotiation
where you don't need it well you're
actually willing to walk away it's not
posturing
how did that turn out do you end it with
a better deal
did you end up making better do you at
the very least if you didn't end up with
a better deal did you end up making
better decisions where you weren't
forced to compromise right if I need a
new if my car breaks down I've had this
right a car that broke down and I needed
to get a car I needed to get a car
because I was driving from gig to Gig
and I didn't have a car you know what I
got another car that I really had a
replace transmission wasn't well I got a
car and here's what it was a new
transmission and a Ford Taurus would
have been two thousand dollars
the used transmission was sixteen
hundred dollars but at 80 000 miles on
it that was what was currently in the
car I should have said no
but I needed a car and it was what was
available so I compromised
the next time when I was older and I I
was looking to purchase a new car I was
able to walk away
from any dealership I want guess what we
ended up getting a better deal in the
car because I could take my time I
wasn't beholden to them the issue is
Leverage
you don't want to be leveraged by
countries who by the way have no vested
interest in helping the environment we
have more oil than any other country in
the face of the Earth we could Supply
our own Natural Gas
for 98 years and to the general to the
Zoomers out there gen Z you may not know
this does everyone hear you guys
remember we heard growing up about peak
oil remember that remember peak oil peak
oil was supposed to happen I believe in
the 70s 1980s in the 90s that was what
we were raised with the hole in the
ozone CFCs and peak oil
I haven't heard that discussed recently
because that's not the issue now it's oh
it's not about peak oil it's about the
fact that we're using any oil okay we'll
just keep moving the goal posts I don't
know I think the United States has a
vested interest in pulling some
Shenanigans I think it's probably a
concerted effort from
several different International forces
what is that is that fair I think it's
fair yeah I think it's more likely
Russia did it but I'm I I kind of want I
want to fit Putin with a black hat so
yeah I think he deserves it well it'd be
hard to fit the Hat on his head no
that's true yeah yeah he says his head
looks swollen it does looks like it
looks like Mr Mackey a little bit now
syphilis will do that all right we're
going to go play they don't make them
like they used to which we could
absolutely not do on YouTube uh I
believe I'm not sure what I might be
doing a hidden camera thing tomorrow so
I believe David Dave might be but I'll
see you in Oklahoma City if I don't see
you tomorrow I'll see you in Oklahoma
City October 8th this Saturday they're
uh you know a lot of cutter.com there's
some tickets left
uh YouTube is off
foreign
[Music]